with more than 65,000 square feet of
space and a hundred and fifteen rooms
Hearst Castle is one of America's
largest and most treasured homes hearst
castle was built by American newspaper
magnate William Randolph Hearst in 1919
after he inherited 40,000 acres of
farmland he would go on to purchase
200,000 more acres of land allowing him
to create the kind of sprawling compound
rarely seen to this day in addition to
the main house la casa grande Hearst
Castle is comprised of three guest
houses an outdoor pool and numerous
other amenities one of the most
recognizable rooms in the Hearst Castle
is the 345 thousand gallon indoor Roman
pool styled after ancient Roman baths
the pool is decorated with eight statues
of Roman and Greek gods goddesses and
heroes Hearst was known for throwing
lavish parties and hosting important
figures at his San Simeon home Winston
Churchill Charlie Chaplin Cary Grant
Greta Garbo and Calvin Coolidge were
some of the hundreds of house guests the
home was donated to the state of
California in 1958 and welcomes more
than 750,000 visitors every year
you
you